i think it is harder to succeed when
you're disabled
i think there's a lot of the odds are
stacked against you
it's harder to get into into school with
local school
it's harder to go to university it's
harder to get a job
so really success is far further away
when you're starting out however when
you have a disability
you learn certain things like resilience
and communication
just because it's how you get by in
day-to-day life
and if you're able to harness those in
the right direction and the right way
then i think that enables you to be
successful
[Music]
my first tip is dream big i can remember
watching michael palin on the tv and
thinking wow i'd love to just travel the
world like him
when i was at university i decided i
would go for a trip on the other side of
the world
i can remember being at sydney bridge
and looking over the harbour
and having goose bumps on my arms i was
there i'd done it and it was
such an amazing feeling of achievement
i've not been able to stop traveling
ever since
i'm definitely not suggesting that
everyone should do the kind of
adventures i've done
but i think it's very important for
people to push their own comfort zone
because it just gives you so much
confidence and a feeling that you can
achieve anything and you can put that
back into your day-to-day life as well
so my next tip is write 10 ideas a day
creativity is like a muscle when you
have to train it
every morning i write my ten ideas on my
phone
i write down the numbers one to ten i
pick the topic
that could be about business or it could
be about how to improve my health and
well-being
or it could just be about how to have
some fun tomorrow
the point of the exercise is just to
come up with ideas
and there is no pressure or expectation
to actually use any of them
the first five normally come really
quickly but as you're starting to get
near the end it gets
really hard and that's a bit like going
to the gym
you know that you're stretching the
muscle and improving it
say it straight is my next tip
good communication is key to all
relationships in life and personal and
professional
so with my disability sometimes it's
difficult doing handshakes
and there's been some quite awkward
moments where people think i'm leaving
them hanging and it's just a bit
uncomfortable
but i've learned to say quite directly
please can you shake my left hand
because that just enables me not to have
to take my other hand off the joystick
so i would say overall you don't ever
have to be rude
or nasty to people but you should always
speak your truth
my final tip is to make jokes
a good sense of humor is a powerful tool
and it breaks down lots of barriers
particularly in my life there are
definitely times where people
see the wheelchair before they see me
and i could get angry by that
or i could try to be very educating and
serious so i find that humor is a good
way of
putting them at ease and opening up a
more normal and relaxed dialogue
when i look back on the achievements
it's quite surreal
it sometimes has felt the last couple of
years that my life's been like a movie
so i think there's a bit of um it's
still sinking in to some degree as well
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video